la la ferme du loup ravissant ravissant
d'où ça vient ça il y avait un loup
alors peut-être que historiquement il y
a eu un loup oui en effet l'histoire ne
le dit pas euh en fait le le loup
ravissant c'est le lieud du du du du
petit territoire du territoire de
basinville voilà vous êtes à basinville
he c'est ça basinvilleine donc euh et
donc le le liodi s'appelait le le lourd
avisant pour être pour être exact à
l'époque et pour ravisant avant d'être
ravisant voilà c'est ça c'est al voilà
en fait en
fait a priori ouis ce serait une
position du loup qui est en attente un
peu en en en chasse enfin voilà en tout
se ravise et donc c'est devenu le LOU
ravissant parce que c'est un peu
plus c'est c'est magnifique comme comme
comme alors on nous le dit souvent moi
c'est vrai que je l'entends
tellement mais bon je suis ravi que ça
ça plaise ça plaise au consommateurs
alors dans dans dans la ferme on va
parler évidemment du du du canard mais
il y a il y a aussi des tomates des
courches des poireaux des PES de
terre des salades des tomates des
aubergines des courgettes enfin ouai
c'est ça ou on a un atelier de de de
maréchage donc en direct donc plein
champ souser où on développe un panel de
légumes le le plus large possible euh ça
c'est toute l'année évidemment c'est
toute l'année et puis évidemment alors
pour les fêes mais enfin pour d'autres
occasions il y a il y a il y a tous les
produits autour du canard puisque vous
avez un élevage de de canard c'est ça
donc toute l'année on fait du canard
gras sauf juilletaoût et puis un peu au
mois de janvier où on se repose euh mais
sinon toute l'année on on élève du des
canards on les transforme chez nous en
fait le circuit il est extrêmement court
parce que ils arrivent en caneton à la
ferme et puis et puis on les on les
élève pendant 120 jours en en extérieur
dans dans leur parcours oui c'est ça ils
sont totalement à l'extérieur c'est ça
voilà on on les rentre la nuit parce que
à cause du lourd àisant il il reste des
renards en tout cas il y a plusou mais
il reste renard oui il y a des a des
petits prédateurs quand même c'est ça
donc donc ou il faut protéger tout à
fait et puis bon ça nous permet aussi
d'être toujours d'avoir l'œil sur sur
nos animaux tous les jours matin et soir
quoi et et donc on on les élève jusqu'à
120 jours on les engresse pendant 13
jours les 13 derniers jours de le de
leur vie et on les abat chez nous parce
qu'on a l'abattoir agréer on a on a le
laboratoire de transformation à gréer et
de découpe à gréer voilà comme ça on
fait tout de A à Z et et tout est
produit évidemment le maïs que vous leur
donnez alors le maïs c'est un voisin qui
qui est qui qui fait plus de maïs que
moi qui qui me le produit parce que
voilà c'est assez technique aussi le
maïs faut pas qu'il sèche trop vite donc
si je faisais un maïs que j'emmenais à
la coopérative et et il faut une une
certaine variété de maïs aussi donc
voilà c'est un faut vraiment être faut
vraiment être carré là-dessus euh donc
c'est une variété de maïs conditionne la
qualité après du produit quoi c'est ça
qui faut que ça sèche lentement pour pas
dégrader la Midon du maïs pour qu'il
soit plus assimilable pour pour les
volailles voilà pour les volailles oua
et euh donc évidemment ça donne ça donne
beaucoup de
produits apporter quelquesun donc
évidemment le foie gras parce que c'est
avant tout entre guillemets ce à quoi
sert nos canards mais il y a du foie
gras frais voilà il y a un foie cru
frais qui est là voilà donc ça c'est
comm ça qu'on le
présente comme on on a c'est V que les
gens maintenant il sont mis de plus en
plus à faire le le propr oui ils ont
tous ils ont tous leur leur recette
famili ah je dirais pas l'alcool que je
mets dedans par que c'est ma recette
familiale mais très bien et et on est
ravi que chacun a sa recette après quand
on goûte c'est un peu comme le somomon
oh c'est trop
salé nous on a en en toute modeste on a
réussi à trouver un juste équilibre
entre entre tous
les mais ENF c'est très bien non c'est
très bien de le faire
soi-même ça nous permet aussi de de de
proposer sinon il y en a que vous avez
ça onose alors on propose TR gammes de
foie gras donc celui qu'on a amené là le
foie gras mit cuisiné en tyine
porcelaine où là on a juste foie gras
c'est le poivre et un peu d'alcool pour
l'aromatiser on a le foie gras miicit en
bocal où là c'est juste foie gras poivre
et on a le foie gras entier en conserve
ù là c'est juste foie grass et le poivre
la différence entre le miuit et la
conserve c'est évidemment le temps de
cuisson et la température de cuisson le
micu est cuit à 65 75°g et le l'entier
cons à 105°g d'accord donc pour le micu
on est plutôt sur une pasteurisation
alors que sur l'antier conserve on est
vraiment sur une stérilisation et qui
qui souvent la question qu'on me pose
c'est ah oui mais ma femme est enceinte
je techniquement il y a pas de problème
c'est qu' a 75 degr pendant 1 he et demi
donc voilà ah oui on a peur de de quoi
bah des des des problèmes liés à la
viande qui est pas assez cuite pour les
pour lesord mais nous on on est on est
dans il il y a eu des problèmes de
grippe aviaire gripe avia ou on a
pendant un an alors pas directement chez
chez nous mais mais elle a été
foudroyante he C cette avière à tel
point
que les les couvoirs donc ceux qui nous
distribuent les
cons ont dû arrêter pendant un lapse de
temps de de de distribuer des cantetons
parce que déjà il y avait des
restrictions de transport et parce
qu'ils ont dû abattre aussi une partie
des chaptel reproducteur donc les mâles
et les femelles qui font des des œufs
pour voilà donc du coup quasiment
pendant un an on n pas eu de caneton on
n' pas pu produire bon voilà on avait un
peu de stock mais on est arrivé à fin
juin 2023 où on avait quasiment écoulé
tous les stock donc fallait reprendre
alors on a repris les l'élevage à partir
dei pardon mai
2023 pour pour les premiers abattages
fin août 2023 d'accord et oui évidemment
c'est une crainte qu'on ah c'est une
épée de d'amoclass qu'on a toute l'année
souvent souvent là là en plus ce qui se
passe avec les périodes migratoires donc
à partir de novembre souvent là c'est on
croise les doigts pour pas qu'on ait de
problème donc ça revient un petit peu là
mais en fait il y a une gripe av
tellement froyante que que les autorités
sanitaires ont mis le ont mis le paquet
pour sortir
desau et puis et puis et puis trouver
des vaccins trou des vaccins oui oui
c'est ça il y a des vaccins ils ont
sorti voilà depuis quelques temps des
vaccins contre la gripe aviaère donc il
y a tout un programme un processus à
mettre en place ils ont démarré les
campagnes de vaccination donc moi je
vais pas tarder voilà pour pour certains
lot commencer à les vacciner pour en
tout cas pas qu'elle se diffuse c'est ça
ça ou alors la priorité dans les
premiers dans les premiers écho c'était
de de vacciner les reproducteurs h parce
qu'en fait il y avait un coupt du vaccin
quand même donc engendrer enfin
répercuter un coup de vaccin sur un
caneton ça aurait été un petit peu un
petit peu compliqué alors que sur les
producteurs qui eux vont potentiellement
faire plus caneton voilà c'était un peu
plus un peu plus logique bon visiblement
visiblement il y aura quand même des
campagnes de vaccination chez les sveurs
et bon ça nous permet de maintenir
activité cou c'est un coup mais c'est
pris plus ou moins en charge mieux c'est
mieux d'avoir un coup et d'avoir une
production c'est ça ou de ne pas rien
produire pendant un
an alors on a des FO ça c'est c'est sous
alors voilà leam comme ça cuisin en
terine porcelaine il est mis sous vide
il a une DLC d'un mois et il se
maintient au frais il se maintient au
frais et ça c'est ça marche très très
bien pour le fait il y a juste
l'avantage dira du svide comme ça c'est
que nous quand on les cuit donc dans
l'autoclave quand on les sort on les
presse comme ça le gras il sort un petit
peu de la terrine et donc ça nous permet
de d'enlever le maximum de gras et
proposer souvent le problème enfin
souvent ça nous arrive que en conserve
une fois qu'on met toujours par exemple
pour un bocal de 100 g on va mettre 120
125 presque 130 g de matière parce que
le foie ça fond c'est toujours un peu
pareil le le la bête noire du foie gras
c'est ESS de fondre à la cuisson donc on
met toujours on essaie de charger au
maximum nos conserves pour
limiter qu' reste un maximum de fois
gras et pas trop de gras mais la
conserve une fois qu'elle est sertie on
peut plus y toucher donc une fois
qu'elle est sertieelle est mis dans
l'autoclave on a pu mettre de du T de
fond donc c'est pour ça qu'il y a
toujours un peu moins de gras dans dans
un miuit parce que il est cuit à 4 75
que dans une conserve mais l'avantage de
de la terine sous vide c'est que là on
enlève le gras après enfin on peut
enlever le gras aprèsi on le presse on
le laisse refroidir comme ça le gras
fige et voilà quand on le démoule on
enlève le GR l'enlever ah oui donc ça
fait un produit ça fait un produit où il
y a moins de gras alors que dans une
conserve potentiellement vous pouvez
acheter un peu de gras c'est bon après
les cuisiniers les cuisiniers qui qui
qui aiment cuisiner ils conservent le
gras et puis cuisine avec le gras c'est
on vend on vend des bocos simplement
avec de la graisse parce que il y a des
cuisiniers qui qui cuisinent petite
pomme de TER salardaise revenu à la
graisse de Calar et la graisse de car
est une excellente graisse d'ailleurs
pour ceux qui cuisinent mieux que mieux
que de l'huile ou du beur la CAN il a
rien vous faites du FO restant ouai
celui de jefrey ouel bien
sû je le fais on l'achète en l'OB
d'IT et alors après il y a d'autres
produits il y a par exemple les riettes
de canard c'est ça alors comme on a
enfin on est quand même soucieux un
petit peu de de ce qu'on fait on on
jette le le minimum à la poubelle en
quelque sorte donc on valorise on essaie
de valoriser tout la toute la viande du
canard donc évidemment les Magris que
qu'on fend sou vide à l'unité les
aiguillettes alors aiguillett c'est un
tout petit filet de de viande qui est
entre la carcasse et le magret qui est
très subtile les cuisses qu'on valorise
en confit ou alors évidemment bah oui ou
alors en choucrû on a une recette de
choucrout de lentill voilà de cassoulet
au confit de canard chouout au canard
choucrout au confit de canard ouais
c'est extra faut goûter c'est c'est
c'est extra et évidemment bah avec tout
le reste de la viande bah on fait des
riettes 100 % canard où on rajoute on
rajoute même un peu de gras de canard
parce que sinon elles sont un peu trop
sèches mais on ne rajoute pas de gras de
porc donc potentiellement c'est ce qui
c'est ce qui ce qui peut faire des
riettes un petit peu cher moins grasse
que que moins grass que des Res de des
riettes de por en général ou même des
riettes de canard qu'on trouve dans je
dirais de industriel où il rajoute un
petit peu de bah parce que ça coûte
beaucoup moins cher pourcentage de GR il
a en fait il y a une réglementation
quand même à à respecter euh sur sur sur
les riettes ou pour avoir l'appellation
euh l'appellation rillett de canard
c'est faut qu'il y ait au moins 23 % de
ah d'accord il semble que c'est 23 % de
de de viande de canard nous laissé 100 %
voilà ça c'est c'est pas pareil on se
pose pas de questions on se pose pas de
questions voilà là encore oui c'est ça
l'avantage d'aller alors euh évidemment
il y a il y a une boutique euh y a une
boutique au du L ravissant à Basille
trois routes de richbour à basaville euh
qui est ouverte je crois que moi j'ai vu
que c'était le mercredi le vendredi
après-midi et le samedi le matin c'est
ça ça alors en période tout ça c'est
c'est nos horaires de toute l'année ou
en période de fitete voilà évidemment on
est ouvert un peu plus régulièrement sur
sur les créneaux juste avant Noël
justement pour aè vous avez un site
aussi he il est en construction mais il
y a il y a P Facebook il y a un numéro
de téléphone il y a aucun problème où il
y a tout les horaires sur sur sur le
répondeur et il y a le voilà le facebook
de la ferme du lavissant où il y a
toutes les informations également très
bien c'est génial hein c'est génial
c'est vrai c'est vrai que c'est un li
magnifique et vous vous êtes donc le
dernier producteur de foas dans les
ivelines ouais c'est ça ou des ivelines
mais il y a du FO gras des ivelines
voilà ça mais il y en a quasiment plus
non plus en l'Î de France quoi valdoise
il y en a plus dans les soles il y en a
il doit en rester
un alors peut-être que le métier inras
peut-être que en fait c'est un petit peu
je dirais comme ça reste un élevage donc
il y a besoin de d'être présent
quasiment tout le temps une prophylaxie
à à suivre et puis c'est un peu je
dirais c'est un peu comme le lait
c'estàdire que pour l'engraissement
c'est matin et
soir l'année donc en fait et puis c'est
tôt le matin jusqu'à potentiellement
tard le soir donc en fait il y a des
contraintes horaires qui sont qui sont
là aussi après moi j'ai j'ai pris le
parti de
de de pas de continuer l'activité parce
queil y a un super
savoir-faire oui ça commence en
87 donc voilà
vousexpérience et puis c'est quand même
un des fleurons de la gastronomie
française le FO qu'on se le dise il y a
un sairfire il y a il y a il y a un il a
a une zone de chalandise comme le disait
euh notre ami de de qui est énorme en
Île-de-France donc donc voilà c'est un
peu un Paris et puis et puis on y va
hein faut mais bravo merci bravo donc
voilà la ferme du LOU ravissant à
basinville et puis donc il y a la
boutique où on peut aller acheter des
des des produits euh c'est ça c'est vous
vendez que chez vous alors non non on a
des partenaires revendeurs euh beaucoup
dans les ivelines quelqu à Paris voilà
d' d'accord également des des des
produits de de nos confrères producteurs
éleveur ou voil l'objectif voilà nous
nos produits ENF j'ai j'ai j'ai pris le
parti prix de
de de de donner l'exclusivité à soit des
des producteurs des des fermes cuillett
ou des des producteurs collègues ou aux
épiceries
fines j'ai été démarché par des grandes
surfaces moi aujourd'hui voil c'est pas
un créneau c'est pas un créneau que que
que je veux prendre pour pas valoriser
notre produit parce qu'en fait
aujourd'hui typiquement une rillette 100
% canard en grande surface si elle est
mise à côté d'une
rillette d'un industriel les gens vont
la trouver trop cher donc il en fait ils
vont me cataloguer tout de suite en trop
cher alors que c'est pas du tout le même
produit le mê produit donc donc oui ça
s'appelle riette mais ça n'a rien à voir
lire les étiquettes exactement bah oui
oui mais enfin le consommateur il voit
le prix et puis c'est tout quoi il
s'arrête là et puis ça permet aussi de
de de de donner un je veux dire une
exclusivité à certains
vendeurs qui vont valoriser un peu mieux
produits quoi très bien génial merci
merci à vous